It's great to welcome to the program today,
crystal ball, who's a journalist, [inaudible]
cohost of the Hills
rising and also author of the book, the populous
guide to 2020 a new right and new left are
rising. A great to have you on. Crystal.
Thank you so much for having me, David. I
really appreciate it.
So to start with, um, we hear from Steve Bannon
all about Donald Trump's populism and of course
that version of populism is very different
than what we see espoused by people like Bernie
Sanders. It's very different from what we
saw in Tahrir square, occupy wall street and
so on and so forth. How would you kind of
characterize the main differences between
right populism and left populism?
It's such a good question. Such an important
question and one that we do try to grapple
with some in the book. And I mean, as you're,
just to give a little bit of context here
and your viewers probably know some of this,
but on our show, rising on the left populous
toast and my cohost soccer is the right populous
toast and we have many disagreements about
how politics should be prosecuted here and
around the world. Um, but what we try to do
in the book is explore the idea of what politics
could look like in the future if instead of
having a situation that I believe we have
now, where both political parties essentially
fight for the needs of the rich and that comes
with a certain bipartisan consensus. You know,
I think it's a myth that there's just gridlock
in Washington. In fact, there's quite a lot
of consensus around the war machine.
There's been a lot of consensus around trade
deals. Um, there's been a lot of consensus
around cutting taxes for corporations and
creating loopholes that allow corporations
to get away with paying less in taxes. We
just saw it, you know, ad day after impeachment
Democrats partner with Trump to pass his new
trade deal. Right? So there has been a lot
of bipartisan consensus where would be the
overlap and where would be the difference
if you had, you know, a Steve Bannon sort
of right-wing party and a Bernie Sanders left
wing party that were both, at least in rhetoric,
trying to fight to win over the working class
of America. So that being said, look, my politics
on the left are very much of the view that
we need to put the working class, not just
here, but around the world at the center of
our politics and really fight for their interests,
not just try to appeal to racial anxiety in
a cheap way that I think we've seen by the
right in this country, certainly Donald Trump,
Steve Bannon, etc.
And that we see around the world as well.
Now the great thing about sovereign, for those
who have watched the show, you know this,
he comes at these things from a, from a very
genuine perspective of he really believes
that immigration restriction ism is going
to be better for working class people here.
He really believes in this nationalist view
that says basically we have to take care of
our people first. That's primary. And then
after we do that, we can look around the world.
Whereas I see much more of an importance between
solidarity of working class peoples around
the globe. So that's kind of the essential
difference between the two of us. He, as you
know, is, is critical of Donald Trump. On
many things, critical of the ban Bannon view
on many things. Um, but he comes at this from
a sort of genuine and non-racist place, which,
you know, can be unusual in certain circles
in the right.
Yeah. Well, I mean, I think, uh, so one interesting,
I'm a academic who studies populism is a Federico
Finkelstein at the new school in New York
city, and he's talked a lot about how, in
a sense, neoliberal globalization and the
anxieties it produces, either consciously
or subconsciously, are responsible for a lot
of the rise in both left and right wing populism
in the United States and around the world.
The difference is that on the right, a lot
of it becomes cultural anxiety, the anxiety
about losing what some considered to be a
privileged status in society. And then on
that leads to a sort of politics, more based
out of fear in right wing populism, which
is where you get the nationalist stuff and
you get the, yeah. Populism for the people
that we define to be inside of our circle,
not so much for the people outside of it,
which is in a sense what you're, you're kind
of alluding to as well.
Well, awesome. Let's see. You also say, if
I can just, uh, echo that you also see a pairing
of that, you know, use of like white racial
anxiety with a fundamentally corporatist view.
So that's what I've seen in the Trump administration.
They throw these bones of sort of identity
politics, racial anxiety, politics to the
white working class. Meanwhile, it's the same
Paul Ryan corporatist agenda of making sure
Amazon can get away with not paying any taxes
that we've seen for decades. So there's a
lack of, um, genuine care and concern for
the working class. I mean, the latest Trump
budget has him co cutting entitlements, right?
That's what he's advocating for. Something
that he explicitly said he would not do in
his campaign. And that is not just here. That's
something that commonly unfolds around the
globe as well.
Yeah, I mean, we've seen the, those right
wing populist ideas. I mean, certainly Trump,
uh, Nigel Farage in the U K Modi of India,
you could make an argument. There's elements
of that. Even even Erdogan in Turkey, it feels
to me a populism of us together against them,
right? Versus what you talked about in terms
of inclusion of more, the concept of us against
them is flawed. It's about all of us together.
And that's kind of how I would summarize it
at the top level in a sense.
Yeah, I think that's right. And look, I think
neoliberalism is kind of the mirror image
of that. You have a, um, uh, selling out of
the, you know, diverse working class, uh,
base of the party and on economic issues and
the way they keep them in the 10. It's just
basically being like, well, at least we're
not racist like the GOP, you know, so it's
a pretty, you know, and that, that's effective
because yeah, you don't want to vote for a
party that has contempt for you. So of course
you stay in the tent, but actually trying
to deliver a, uh, economic populous message
that would cut across all racial and gender
lines. And appeal to the broad working class
in America. Democratic party hasn't been doing
that for a long time. And so in the book,
what we try to do, and David, you get this
because we watched like CNN and MSNBC and
how they get literally everything wrong like
you and you would have thought there would
have been some soul searching.
You're like, what are we not understanding
about the American electorate at this point?
But no, they haven't done any of that. And
so if they had been correct right now, Camila
and beta would be battling it out for the
nomination, right? Bernie Sanders was supposed
to be yesterday. They still don't believe
that he could be the nominee when obviously
he, he is the farmer. He has the clearest
shot at becoming the democratic nominee. So
what our thesis is, which I suspect you'll
agree with this, is you can't understand politics
today and understand the rise of Trump and
understand the rise of Bernie and AOC and
the new left in the country. If you don't
grapple with the core rot in America, why
is it that the top line numbers, the GDP in
the stock market is so good? And yet you have
people literally killing themselves at record
and historic rates, like what went wrong there.
And if you don't understand that anger and
the way that our drives our politics, you're
going to be completely confused by everything
that you see unfolding in our politics right
now.
So let's talk a little bit about the Bernie
Trump
thing. So there, there are some who say, and
this is not my view, but I want to explore
it with you, that the um, sort of crossover
appeal from a Bernie supporter to Trump or
vice versa is a significant, let's call it
non-zero to some degree. And one of the, the,
um, facts that some try to cite is look at
how many Bernie primary voters in 2016 ultimately
voted for Trump. Now, I don't think that's
a very good argument because not that many
did. I mean, if you look at, I think it was
about one in 10 Bernie primary voters voted
Trump. And if you look at 2008, uh, you had
a higher share of Hillary primary voters who
voted McCain. So like, I don't believe that
the mathematical argument is a good one. But
the philosophical argument about even though
it seems as though Bernie and Trump are so
different that there is something of a crossover
appeal, how valid do you think that assessment
is?
Look, it's, I always get nervous about this
because they are very different politicians
with very different views, approaches, you
know, values, all of those things where I
see most of the parallels and it look, we
can point to the obvious policy things right
on trade. There are a lot of similarities,
um, on at least some of the stances. Donald
Trump claimed to hold in that race against
Hillary Clinton, even on healthcare. I mean,
he basically supported a single payer system
in that race. Um, he backs lifting the minimum
wage. He said he would never cut entitlements.
Like there were some parallels there, although
I think those were more rhetorical than, you
know, actually the way that he's governed
to explore that a tiny bit more, not tend
to rub, but sure. Trump was so obviously pandering
in line when he said those things. Should
we even consider them agreements when they
were so transparently untrue?
I don't think. And I don't think so. But you
know, on trade, I think there are actually
a lot of, that's the one area where he has
been more or less, you know, consistent with
the way that he ran. And there are parallels
there. But I don't even think that that's
really the most important thing. I think the
more important parallel is the antiestablishment
dynamic. And look, there are lots of things
to criticize Donald Trump about. Lord knows,
and I've, I've criticized him on plenty of
them, but there's also been, um, you know,
attempts to just completely smear everyone
who voted for him as racist or sexist, et
cetera, and just miss the entire movement
and condemn the every, you know, person who
would ever support him in that way. That we
see basically playing out right now with the
whole birdie bro narrative that Oh, you have
to be toxic or problematic to support Bernie
Sanders.
Um, I do think that the media, look, I, you
know, hate to stick up for him, but I do think
the media has been unfair in the fact that
every single story on CNN and MSNBC pass to
have a Trump is bad angle, which is just,
you know, it becomes caricature, right? Not
every last thing that the man does is bad.
A lot of it is, but not everything is, and
also not every story is about him. So like
I covered the, the teachers' movement extensively,
which was incredibly significant, largest
sort of labor uprising that we've had certainly
in my lifetime. And it got so little play
on these networks that claim to care about
these working class values because it didn't
have a tidy Trump angle. So there's also just
this, you know, incredible inability to understand
why anyone would genuinely support him for
non racist or sexist or nefarious reasons
that I see paralleled with Bernie Sanders.
So for example, you have, um, Chuck Todd just
recently equating Sanders supporters to Brown
shirts, like the supporters of the guy who
could be the first Jewish president who lost
relatives in the Holocaust. Are compared to
Brown shirts something that the ADL condemned
him for? Um, it's hard not to see a similar
sort of smearing of Trump supporters as well.
No doubt about it. And I think we're, where
the rubber sort of ultimately meets the road
on the sort of non-Trump stories is that it's
not only that there's not a tidy Trump angle
sometimes, but in general stories that don't
have like a coherent beginning, middle and
end where you said, this is, this is the start
and the story has now ended, those stories
get less coverage. And that's why the judges
issue, which I've been talking about, which
is of course, I mean these are people that
are being selected by Trump, but whoever is
the Republican president would be selecting
similar judges are coming by and being approved
by the Senate, confirmed by the Senate, and
there's barely any coverage of it. It's not
really a Trump story, but it's a story that
will affect the country for decades.
And it's a general, I mean, exactly right.
My children and their children will be dealing
with the fallout of that development. There's
also, um, a reluctance to cover stories in
which Democrats are also complicit, right.
So, um, you know, war making, right? The fact
that they basically, the democratic establishment
basically gave him a blank check just as they
have for every president since nine 11 to
do whatever he wants overseas. That doesn't
get nearly as much energy. Even though in
my view, it's much more dangerous to American
public and to world stability. Then even,
you know what he did in Ukraine, which wasn't
okay, it wasn't acceptable, but there's so
much more heat and obsession around that than
the fact that he, you know, almost stumbled
us into war with Iran, which would have massive
implications for decades to come. Those things
are not covered on an equal basis at all because
there's so much democratic complicity in the
ladder.
We've been speaking with crystal ball journalist,
pundit cohost of the Hills rising and also
co author of the book, the populous guide
to 2020 a new right, a new or rising
crystal. Really appreciate your time. Great.
Great being with you, David. Thank you so
much.